I really think that what we really need
to teach is not the stuff that you
should know but the process by which you
know it and that's the one thing that I
think is most important for people to
carry on the details of science are
fascinating for me and you and I think
for most people once they realize it's
science a lot of people don't realize
they're interested in science because
they don't know what science of course
the basic things people should
understand about the world is that there
was a big bang the universe is expanding
Evolution happened but more important
the process by which we get that
information the process by which we test
it because those are the tools that
people will carry with them all of the
areas aspects of life and if we just
used the scientific method then politics
would be more sensible and more rational
because people would test the ideas of
politicians but politicians might also
develop policies based on empirical
evidence